the whole process of natural selection
is to some degree dependent on the idea
of variation that within any population
of a species you have some
genetic variation so for example you
know let's say i have a bunch of
well this is the circle species and you
know one guy is that color and then i
got a bunch
more maybe some are that color oh that's
the same color that one and that one and
that one and for whatever reason and
some sometimes there are no
environmental factors that will
predispose one of these guys to be able
to survive and reproduce over the other
but every now and then there might be
some environmental factor and it makes
maybe all of a sudden this guy is more
fit to reproduce and so for whatever
reason this guy is able to reproduce
more frequently
and these guys less frequently and some
of them got get killed or whatever eaten
by birds or whatever or they're just not
able to reproduce for whatever reason
and then maybe these guys are something
in between and so over time the the
frequency of the different traits you
see in this population will change and
if they are drastic enough maybe these
guys start becoming dominant and start
not liking these guys because they're so
different or whatever else we could see
a lot of different reasons these could
this could eventually turn into a
different species
now
the obvious question is is what leads to
this variation
right in a population sorry in a
population what leads to this you know
in fact even in our population what
leads to one person having you know
dirty blonde hair one person having
brown hair one person having black hair
and you know we have uh the the spectrum
of skin complexions and and and heights
is pretty much infinite what causes that
and then one
thing that i kind of point to and we
talked about this a little bit in the
dna video
is this notion of mutations you know dna
we learned is just a sequence of these
bases so
adenine guanine let's say i got some
thymine going i have some more adenine
some cytosine and that these code if you
have enough of these in a row maybe you
have a few hundreds or a few thousands
of these these code for proteins or they
code for things that control other
proteins but maybe you have a change in
one of them
maybe this cytosine for whatever reason
becomes a guanine randomly or maybe
these get deleted and that would change
the dna now but you can imagine i mean
if if i went to someone's computer code
and just randomly started changing
letters and randomly started
inserting letters without really knowing
what i'm doing most of the time i'm
going to break the computer program most
of the time the great majority of the
time this is going to go nowhere
go nowhere
it'll either do nothing for example if i
go into someone's computer program and
if i just add a couple of spaces or
something that might not change the
computer program but if i start getting
rid of semicolons and start changing
numbers and all that it'll probably make
the computer program break so we'll
either do nothing or it'll actually kill
the organisms most of the time
mutations
mutations sometimes they might make the
actual cell kind of go run amok and
we'll do a whole maybe series of videos
on cancer and and that itself obviously
would uh hurt the organism as a as a
whole although if it occurs after the
organism is reproduced it might not be
something that selects against the
organism but anyway and it also wouldn't
be passed on but anyway i won't go too
detailed to that but this
the whole point is that mutations don't
seem to be a satisfying source of
variation they could be a source or kind
of contribute on the margin but there
must be something more profound than
mutations that's creating the diversity
even within or maybe i should call the
variation even within a population and
the answer here is really it's kind of
right in front of us it it it really
addresses kind of one of the most
fundamental things about biology and
it's so fundamental that a lot of people
never even question why it is the way it
is and that is
sexual reproduction
sexual
reproduction
and when i mean sexual reproduction it's
this notion that you have and
pretty much if you look at all cells
that have all organisms that have that
have nucleuses and we call those
eukaryotes maybe i'll do a whole video
on eukaryotes versus prokaryotes but
it's the notion that
if you look universally all the way from
plants not universally but if you look
at you cells that have nucleuses they
almost universally have this phenomenon
that you have males
you have males and you have females in
some organisms an organism can be both a
male and a female but the common idea
here is is that
that both that all organisms kind of
produce versions of their genetic
material that mix with other organisms
version of their genetic material if
mutations were the only source of
variation then you know i could just
butt off
other cells
you know maybe other cells would just
butt off from me and then you know
randomly one sal might be a little bit
different and whatever else but that
would as we already talked about most of
the time we would have very little
change very little variation and
whatever variation does occur because of
any kind of
noise being introduced into this into
this kind of
budding process where i just replicate
myself identically most of the times
it'll be negative most of the times
it'll break the organism
now when you have sexual reproduction
what happens well you keep mixing and
matching every possible combination of
dna in in in a in a kind of a a in a
species
pool of dna let me let me make this a
little bit more concrete for you
so let me erase this horrible drawing i
just did
so we all have
we all let me stick to humans because
that's what we are we have
we have 23 pairs of chromosomes
and each of those
in each pair we have one chromosome from
our mother and one chromosome from our
father so let me draw that so i'll do my
father's chromosomes in blue so i have
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 and i'm running out of space
let me do more here 16 17 18
19 20 21
and then i'll throw another one here
that looks a little bit different i'll
throw one here that looks like a y
and we'll talk more about the x's in the
y chromosomes and i have 23 chromosomes
from my mother
and not to be stereotypical but maybe
i'll do that in a in a more feminine
color
let's see so i have 23 chromosomes from
my mother
one two i just have to draw one three
four 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21 22
so what's going on here i have 23
from my mother
i have 23 from my father
23 from my
from my father now each of these
chromosomes and i and i made them right
next to each other so for let me let me
zoom in on one
pair of these
so let's say we look at chromosome
number
you know i'll just call it this
chromosome number three
so let me zoom in on chromosome number
three i have one from my mother
right here and remember actually maybe
i'll do it this way remember chromosome
is just it's just a big if you take the
dna
the dna it just keeps wrapping around it
actually wraps around all these proteins
and it creates the structure but it's
just a big you see it like that you're
like oh maybe the dna you know no but
this has this could have millions of
base pairs so you know maybe it'll look
something like that it's a densely
wrapped
version of a well it's a long string of
dna and when it's normally drawn like
this which is not always the way it is
and we'll talk more about like that they
draw it is densely packed like that so
let's say that's from my mother
and that's from my father now
these are both we call them you know
i'll call them they're the same
let's call this chromosome three
they're both chromosome three and what
the idea is here is that i'm getting
different traits from my father and from
my mother for example and i'm doing a
gross oversimplification here but this
is really to just give you the idea of
what's going on
this this this chromosome 3 maybe it
contains this trait for hair color and
maybe my father
my father had
had i'll use my actual example my father
had very straight hair
so you know let's say he had some place
on this on this chromosome there is a
gene for hair straightness let's say
it's a little thing right there and you
remember that gene could be thousands of
base pairs but let's say this is hair
straightness so my father's
version of that gene or the he had the
allele for straightness and remember an
allele is just a version of a gene
allele so i'll call it the allele
straight
for straight hair
for straight hair now
this other chromosome that my mother
gave me this
this essentially there are exceptions
but for the most part it codes for the
same genes and that's why i put them
next to each other so this will also
have the gene for hair straightness or
curliness but my mom does happen to
actually have curly hair
so she has the gene right there for
curly hair so she has the
the version of the gene here is let's
see allele curly the gene just says look
this is the gene for whether or not your
hair is curly each version of the gene
is called an allele
allele curly
now when i got both of these in my body
or in my cells and these this is in
every cell of my body every cell of my
body except for and we'll talk a little
in a few seconds about my germ cells but
every cells other than the ones that i
use for reproduction have this complete
set of chromosomes in it which i find
amazing but only certain chromosomes are
for example this if these genes will be
completely useless in my fingernails
because all of a sudden the straight and
the curly don't matter that much and i'm
simplifying maybe they will on some
other dimension but let's say for
simplicity they won't matter in certain
places so certain genes are expressed in
certain parts of the body but every
every one of your body cells and we call
those somatic cells
and we'll separate those from the sex
cells or the or the um or the or the um
or the germ cells that we'll talk about
later so this is my body cells
so bodies so this is the great majority
of your cells and this is opposed to
your germ cells and the germ cells i'll
just write it here just so you get it
clear
and for male that's the sperm cells
and for a female that's the egg cells or
the ova
ova
so but most of my cells have a complete
collection of these what i want to give
you the idea is is that for every
for every trait i essentially have two
versions one from my mother and one from
my father now these right here are
called homologous chromosomes
homologous
homologous what that means is you know
every time you see this this the the
prefix you know uh h
homologous or you know if you see like
uh homo sapien or i mean even the word
homosexual or uh uh homogeneous it means
same
right you see that all of the time
so what they what homologous means that
they're almost the same they they they
they're coding they're coding for the
same for the most part the same set of
genes but they're not identical they're
not identical they actually uh they
might code for slightly different
versions of the same gene so depending
on what versions i get you know my what
is actually expressed for me so my
genotype let me introduce another word
and i'm overwhelming you with words here
so my genotype
is exactly what g what alleles i have
what versions of the gene so i got like
you know the fifth version of the curly
allele there could be multiple versions
of the of the curly allele in our in our
gene pool and maybe i got some version
of the straight allele that is my
genotype
my phenotype
my phenotype is what my hair really
looks like so for example
two people could have different
genotypes with the same but they might
code for hair that looks pretty much the
same so it might have a very a very
similar phenotype so one phenotype can
be represented by multiple genotypes so
that's just one thing to to to think
about and we'll talk a lot about that in
the future but i just want to introduce
you that into that there now my whole
i entered this whole discussion because
i wanted to talk about variation so how
does variation happen well what's going
to happen when i so first of all
well let me put it this way what's going
to happen when i reproduce and and and i
have i have a son well
my son my contribution to my son is
going to be a random collection of half
of these genes
i'm going to contribute either one for
each homologous pair i'm either going to
contribute the one that i got from my
mother or the one that i got from my
father
right so let's say that the the the
sperm cell that
went on to to fertilize my wife's egg it
just happened to have let's say it
happened to have
that one
that one well i could just pick one from
each of these 23 sets and you could say
well how many combinations are there
well for every set there's two i can
pick one of two different
i could pick one of the two homologous
chromosomes and i'm going to do that 23
times
2 times 2 times 2 is 2 to the 23rd so
there's 22 to the 23 different versions
that i can contribute to my to my to any
son or daughter that i might have
and we'll talk about how that happens
when we talk about meiosis or mitosis
that when i generate my sperm cells
sperm cells are essentially takes one
they they you have you have instead of
having 23 pairs of chromosomes in sperm
you only have 23 chromosomes so for
example i'll take one from each of those
and through the process of meiosis which
we'll go into i'll generate a bunch of
sperm cells
and each sperm cell
each sperm cell will have one from each
of these pairs
one version from each of those pairs so
if maybe for chromosome
this chromosome i get it from my dad i
get you know from the next chromosome i
get it from my mom then i get a couple
then i donate a couple more from i
shouldn't draw them next to each other i
donate a couple more from my mom then
for the chromosome number
five it comes from my dad and so on and
so forth but there's two to the 23rd
combinations here because there are 23
pairs that i'm collecting from now my
wife's egg is going to have the same
situation there are 2 of the 23
different combinations of dna that she
can contribute just based on which which
of the homologous pairs she will
contribute so if so the the possible
combinations that just one couple can
produce
and this is you know i'm using my my
life as an example
but you could use this this applies to
everything this applies to every
species that experiences sexual
reproduction
is that so if i can give 2 to 20 to the
23rd
combinations of dna and my wife can give
2 to the 23 combinations of dna then we
can produce 2 to the
46th combinations now just to give an
idea of how large of a number this is
this is 12 000 roughly 12 000 times the
number of human beings on the planet
today so there's a huge amount of
variation that even one couple can
produce and and if you thought that even
that isn't enough it turns out that
amongst these homologous pairs you and
we'll talk about when this happens in
meiosis you can actually have dna
recombination and all that means is that
when these homologous pairs during
meiosis line up near each other you can
have this thing called crossover
where all of this dna here crosses over
and over and touches over here and all
of this dna crosses over and touches
over there so all of this goes there and
all of this goes there what you end up
with
after the crossover
is that one dna the one that came from
my mom
or that i thought came from my mom now
has a chunk that come came from my dad
and the chunk that came from my dad
now has a chunk that came from my mom
let me do that right color
it came from my mom like that and so
that even increases the amount of
variety even more so you can almost now
instead of talking about the different
chromosomes that you're contributing
where the chromosomes are each of these
collections of dna you're now talking
about you can almost go to the different
combinations at the gene level and now
you can think about an almost infinite
form of area of variation and you can
think about
all of the variation that might emerge
when you start mixing and matching
different versions of the same gene in a
population and you don't just look at
one gene i mean the reality is is that
genes by themselves very seldom code for
a specific
you can very seldom look for one gene
and say oh that is brown hair or look
for one g and say oh that's intelligence
or that is uh how likable someone is
it's usually a whole set of genes
interacting in an incredibly complicated
way you know hair might be coded for by
this whole set of genes on multiple
chromosomes and this might be coded for
a whole set of genes on multiple
chromosomes and so then you can start
thinking about all of the different
combinations and then all of a sudden
maybe some combination that never
existed before all of a sudden emerges
and that's very successful but i'll
leave you to think about because
maybe that combination might be passed
on or it may not be passed on because of
this recombination but we'll talk more
about that in the future but i wanted to
introduce this idea of sexual
reproduction to you because this really
is the main source of variation
variation
within a population and i mean to me
it's kind of a philosophical idea
because we we almost take the idea of of
having males and females for granted
because it's this it's this universal
idea but i did a little reading on it it
turns out that this actually only
emerged about 1.4 billion years ago that
before that this is almost a useful
trait because once you introduce this
level of variation the natural selection
can start
you can kind of say that when you have
this more powerful form of variation
than just pure mutations uh and maybe
you might have some primitive form of
crossover before but now that you have
the sexual reproduction
and you have this variation natural
selection can occur in a more efficient
way so that species that were able to
reproduce and essentially recombine
their dna and mix and match it in this
way were able to produce more variety
and were able to essentially be selected
for the environment in a more efficient
way so they started to essentially
outnumber the ones that couldn't so it
became a kind of a very universal trait
but you know you could have imagined a
world and there are science fiction
books written about this where you have
three genders where you have you know uh
gender one two three you could have ten
genders and it just happens to be that
in on earth uh this this notion of
having two genders turned out to be a
very efficient and stable way of
introducing variation into a population
so hopefully you found that interesting
in the next video i'll go more into the
detail of how exactly meiosis and
mitosis works